nous y sommes mesdames et messieurs je
vous remercie tout d'abord de l'intérêt
que vous portez aux travaux de nos
rapporteur il n'y aurait pas eu
d'affaires benalla si une sanction
appropriée avait été prise dès le 2 mai
2018 par le licenciement de l'intéressé
et l'information du procureur de la
république au titre de l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale le travail qui
s'achève aujourd'hui par la présentation
du rapport de muriel jourda et de jean
pierre sueur a duré près de sept mois
plus de 40 personnes ont été
auditionnées sous serment
une trentaine de demandes d'informations
complémentaires ont été faites auprès de
l'elysée et des ministères concernés
après dépouillement des documents qui
nous ont été remis il y en a près de 500
pages et des témoignages recueillis sous
serment
les rapporteurs ont achevé leur tâche
leur rapport est rendu public sur
autorisation de la commission des lois
qui en a délibéré ce matin pendant plus
de trois heures il sera communiquée dans
la journée
là monsieur le président de la
république à monsieur le premier
ministre il leur appartiendra d'en tirer
les conséquences qu'ils jugeront utiles
au bon fonctionnement de l'état pour que
les faits constatés ne se reproduise pas
l'objet de notre travail et est triple
tout d'abord remplir la mission
fondamentale du parlement dans
l'exercice de ses pouvoirs de contrôle
s'agissait pour nous de faire oeuvre de
vérité de rendre l'état plus transparent
plus efficace plus respectueux du droit
et permettre aux français de se faire
leur propre jugement
grâce au caractère public de tous nos
travaux et grâce aussi au caractère
public de ce rapport cela doit permettre
de renforcer pour l'avenir la prévention
des abus de pouvoir
nos travaux n'aurait-il lui que ce
résultat pour les centaines de milliers
de françaises et de français qui nous
ont suivis que ce résultat serait déjà
très important pour notre démocratie
les médias eux mêmes ont pu développer
certaines de leurs investigations très
utile en prenant appui sur les
déclarations publiques qui ont été
recueillis au cours de nos auditions
cette mission est essentielle nous
l'avons rempli je crois sereinement mais
sans inhibition en toute indépendance
en prenant le temps qu'il fallait
c'est un rôle que de notre point de vue
le sénat était particulièrement à même
de tenir car c'est une assemblée
parlementaire libre indépendante
non-alignés sa tradition c'est celle du
dialogue et de la recherche du consensus
c'est aussi celle du pluralisme en
témoigne le fait que la majorité
parlementaire du sénat et l'opposition
du sénat se sont réunis pour travailler
ensemble dans le seul souci de faire
émerger la vérité
notre deuxième objectif c'était de
proposer des mesures propres à éviter le
renouvellement des désordres constatés
prévenir et sanctionner les conflits
d'intérêts parmi les collaborateurs des
cabinets pour qu'il ne soit dans la main
de personne
garantir le respect des standards de
sécurité les plus élevées en ce qui
concerne la protection du président de
la république et celle du premier
ministre
mieux encadré
la délivrance l'utilisation le retrait
des passeports diplomatiques et de
service
faire en sorte que les promotions dans
la réserve de la gendarmerie nationale
soit mieux réguler et plus généralement
veiller à ce que les collaborateurs des
autorités politiques n'interfère pas
avec le fonctionnement opérationnel des
administrations ceci est un point
évidemment très important notre dernière
objectif c'est de faire mieux respecter
pour l'avenir les prérogatives du
parlement
quand il agit en vertu des pouvoirs de
contrôle qu'il tient de la constitution
et de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme dont l'article 15 dit que la
société a droit de demander compte à
tout agent public de son administration
et ce droit fondamental des citoyens
foot et citoyens français nous
l'exerçons nous la représentation
nationale en leur nom et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous ne pouvons tout
simplement pas laisser sans suites
ce que nous considérons comme avoir été
des faux témoignages
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir parce
qu'il en va de l'autorité dû parlement
pour remplir au nom des français
une prérogative tout à fait essentiel
pour la démocratie
nous avons constamment veillé à la
sérénité de nos travaux et au respect de
notre mandat sans jamais répondre aux
pressions ni alimenter des polémiques
autour des rebondissements à répétition
qui ont accompagné nos travaux et que
nous avons subi sans les avoir
provoquées
nous avons également été attentif à ne
pas livrer de conclusion partielle avant
d'avoir achevé un travail méticuleux d'
analyse et d'en avoir délibéré il n'y a
pas une affaire benalla il y à une
affaire de la contrescarpe et du jardin
des plantes
une affaire du permis de port d'armes
irrégulier une affaire de contrat russe
une affaire de passeport diplomatique
une affaire dit mission d'un chargé de
mission dans le bon fonctionnement de la
sécurité président
ciel et c'est principalement cette
affaire-là à laquelle les autres sont
d'ailleurs liées qui depuis le début
aura été le coeur de notre mandat à la
différence de l'assemblée nationale dont
l'anc est visé directement les
événements du 1er mai qui font l'objet
d'une enquête judiciaire
notre mission porter n'est fait et je
cite textuellement le mandat sur la
participation de personnes étrangères
aux forces de sécurité à des activités
de maintien de l'ordre et à la
protection des hautes personnalités
ainsi que sur les sanctions aux
manquements constatés
nous nous sommes donc essentiellement
penché sur la protection du président de
la cinquième puissance du monde dans une
période de l'histoire où les risques
terroristes sont particulièrement élevés
notre président est doté de pouvoirs
constitutionnels très important parmi
les chefs d'exécutifs des grandes
démocraties notamment en matière de
défense
il incarne spécifiquement la continuité
de l'état
sa sécurité n'est pas une affaire
personnelle elle regarde tous les
français elle doit être au niveau des
meilleurs standards internationaux et je
pense d'ailleurs qu'elle l'est au moment
où je vous parle nous avons d'ailleurs
inscrit notre travail dans une approche
comparative avec les systèmes étrangers
pour bien les connaître notre mandat
nous l'avons scrupuleusement respectés
comme nous avons respecté aussi la
mission de la justice et les
prérogatives constitutionnelles du
président de la république
cela ne nous empêchait évidemment pas
d'interroger sous serment d'une part des
personnes faisant l'objet d' enquête
judiciaire et d'autre part des
collaborateurs du chef de l'état comme
ce fut à plusieurs reprises le cas dans
le passé pour de grandes commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale comme
du sénat mais des précautions
particulières s'impose auxquels nous
avons été
très attentif ne pas faire le travail de
la justice ne pas exposer une personne
entendue à s'accuser sous serment ne pas
mettre en cause de décisions ou d'actes
du président de la république et nous
n'avons pas fait mais ne pas renoncer
pour autant à l'exercice de nos propres
prérogatives que nous tenons de la
constitution et que nous exerçons au nom
du peuple français pour l'évaluation du
fonctionnement des services de la
présidence de la république et des
services du gouvernement mis à la
disposition de la présidence de la
république c'est le gars du groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république et du commandement militaire
du palais de l'elysée nous n'étions pas
en charge d'une instruction judiciaire
mais d'une mission de contrôle
parlementaire
nous avons par conséquent enquêter sur
le fonctionnement de l'état est bas sur
les agissements de monsieur benalla
c'est très différent
je peux vous en donner quelques exemples
et nous y reviendrons naturellement tout
à leur place de la contrescarpe ce ne
sont pas les voies de fait que
pourraient caractériser la justice qui
nous intéressait c'était les conditions
dans lesquelles monsieur benalla s'est
trouvée qui venait de décisions
administratives et sait les conséquences
qu'on a tiré de ces votes fait au niveau
des autorités publiques qui pouvaient en
tirer
s'agissant des passeports diplomatiques
ça n'est pas l'utilisation illicite de
ces passeports qui fait l'objet d'une
instruction judiciaire qui nous
intéressait c'était d'expliquer comment
il était possible que ces passeports
soit resté entre les mains de
l'intéressé plusieurs mois après qu'il
ait cessé ses fonctions à l'elysée
s'agissant des contrats russe cdpa le
rôle propre de monsieur benalla dans la
conclusion de ces contrats qui nous
intéressait c les raisons pour laquelle
les rênes
déontologiques qui s'appliquait à la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts il
s'agit d'un conflit d'intérêt majeur
s'il est avéré n'ont pas été mises en
oeuvre ni avant le licenciement ni après
le licenciement de monsieur bénard et
s'agissant de la sécurité présidentielle
naturellement sur quoi nous avons été
sensibles ça n'est pas de caractériser
un certain nombre d'attributs de la
fonction comme des avantages des
privilèges ou pour reprendre
l'expression de monsieur benalla des
caprices c'est de savoir si ces
attributs était caractéristique de la
fonctions réellement exercées par
monsieur bénin en matière de sécurité
puisque c'était l'objet même de notre
travail et c'est une question évidemment
essentiel du point de vue de l'état que
la justice n'est pas en mesure de
traiter chacun son rôle
entre nos différentes institutions
hambourg n'a strictement notre examen à
des questions relatives au
fonctionnement de l'état nous avons
réuni suffisamment d'éléments pour
estimer que la sécurité du président de
la république a été affectée que de
nombreuses erreurs ou anomalies les
défaillances ont été constatées sanction
insuffisante au départ justice tenue à
l'écart permis de port d'armes
irrégulier port d'une arme par monsieur
b nana en présence du président de la
république non respect des règles de
déontologie sur les conflits d'intérêts
maintien en possession de monsieur
benalla d'un téléphone crypté de
passeport diplomatique ou de service
qu'ils n'ont pas été récupérées absence
d' instructions données à la police de
l'air et des frontières de ne pas
permettre à monsieur benalla de sortir
au moyen de ces passeports diplomatiques
ou deux services cela fait tout de même
beaucoup
si bien que les faits constatés le
premier mais apparaissent maintenant
comme la partie émergée d'un iceberg
du point de vue du bon fonctionnement de
l'état les informations qui se sont
accumulés
ensuite sont sans doute plus grave
encore que les événements survenus en
marge de la fête du travail comme l'
ordonnance de 1958 relative à l'exercice
de ses pouvoirs dans quête par le
parlement le prévoit j'ai donc décidé
conjointement avec les deux rapporteurs
et après avoir consulté ce matin la
commission des lois de demander au
président du sénat que le bureau de
notre assemblée c'est la procédure
délibère en vue de saisir le procureur
de la république de paris
des faux témoignages caractérisée de
monsieur benalla des contradictions
apparues entre les premières
déclarations de collaborateurs immédiats
du président de la république sur le
rôle de monsieur benalla en matière de
sécurité et les éléments et témoignages
recueillis par la suite tout en
soulignant d'ailleurs la qualité et la
précision de nombreuses informations qui
nous ont été apportées par les dix
collaborateurs sur d'autres points très
importants
nous souhaitons aussi que l'ensemble du
rapport soit lui même transmis au
procureur de la république afin qu'il
puisse apprécier l'existence éventuelle
d'autres faux témoignage susceptible
d'avoir été commis par des personnes
auditionnées
il appartiendra donc au bureau d'en
décider et les deux rapporteurs se
joignent à moi pour faire cette demande
au bureau je voudrais vous dire en
conclusion que l'autorité qui peut
s'attacher à notre travail vient
essentiellement du respect par les
rapporterait par tous les membres de la
commission des lois
au cours des auditions de notre mandat
que j'ai rappelé mais aussi du respect
des prérogatives du président de la
république d'autonomie aucun acte aucune
décision n'a jamais été mise en cause
par la commission des lois et du respect
de l'autorité judiciaire il y à la part
de l'autorité judiciaire
il y à la part de l' enquête
parlementaire
complémentaires et elles vont dans la
même direction c'est très important de
le dire
nous avons confiance dans les
institutions de la république le
parlement auquel nous appartenons bien
sûr la présidence de la république
l'autorité judiciaire le gouvernement et
nous tenons à ce que cette confiance
soit confortée par les propositions que
nous faisons qui sont des propositions
constructives destinées à éviter qu'à
l'avenir on puisse se retrouver dans ce
genre de situation je vais donc
maintenant donner la parole
successivement à madame jourdain et à
monsieur sueur à moi que je la donne à
monsieur sueur et à madame jourdain et
ils vont vous présenter ma tonne
maintenant le contenu même de leur
rapport madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président de me donner
la parole pour présenter effectivement
d'une façon synthétique mais que nous
pensons néanmoins complète les travaux
que nous avons menées autour de quatre
points que je qualifierais de clés qui
nous sont apparus au fur et à mesure de
nos travaux le premier point est
relative aux sanctions aux sanctions qui
ont pu être prononcée à l'encontre
d'alexandre benalla après le 1er mai
événements qui ont d'abord justifié la
tenue de nos travaux en réalité
plusieurs défaillances ont été mises à
jour dans la réaction des autorités
fonctionnel hiérarchique de monsieur
benalla est également de vincent kra zk
participer aux événements du 1er mai
après ces événements je le dis sans
ambages la commission n'a trouvé ni
approprié à les premières suites qui ont
été apportées aux agissements commis ni
proportionnée les sanctions qui ont été
prétendument infligées et nous avons
regretté l'incompréhensible indulgence
de la hiérarchie d'alexandre benalla qui
a conservé dans l'équipe de l'elysée un
collaborateur qui avait gravement manqué
à ses devoirs et quand jany qu'il avait
gravement manqué à ses devoirs
ça n'est pas de mon avis c'est de l'avis
de toutes les personnes qui ont été
auditionnées par la commission ce qui
frappe en réalité ça n'est pas tant la
sanction qui a été infligé en mai mais
bien la confiance qui a été maintenue
alexandre bénin
jusqu'en juillet tout d'abord nous avons
pu constater ce que je qualifierais
d'une chaîne d'irresponsabilité en
l'absence de signalement immédiat au
parquet de ces faits rappelons-nous
revêtu d'un signe de police selon l'igpn
est peut-être armée sur la voie publique
pour l'un d'eux alexandre benalla et
vincent kraz ont ouvertement le 1er mai
2018 fait usage de la force à l'encontre
de manifestants
les suites pénales aujourd'hui de la
justice mais ces faits présentait déjà
pour les autorités les fonctionnaires
informer tous les indices qui permettait
d'envisager la commission d'un délit et
il appartenait donc à ses fonctionnaires
informer en toute hypothèse de soumettre
la qualification de ces faits au parquet
en application de l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale de façon assez
surprenante c'est la présidence de la
république et non pas le ministère de
l'intérieur qui a été alertée la
première dans la nuit du 1er mai de
l'existence d'une vidéo vidéos des
incidents et c'est également la
présidence de la république qui a
transmis l'information au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet de police
al'inverse plusieurs services plusieurs
services clés dont l'intervention aurait
pu perturber le règlement discret de
cette affaire benalla et bien ont été
maintenus dans l'ignorance jusqu'en
juillet 2018
ni la direction générale de la police
nationale ni l'inspection générale de la
police nationale ni la direction
générale de la gendarmerie nationale ont
été avisés de ces faits aucune des
autorités qu'ils étaient informés
aucune de ces autorités c'est à dire
l'elysée la préfecture de police le
ministère de l'intérieur qui connaissait
ses agissements ne les a signalé au
procureur de paris
chacune se défaussant a posteriori sur
l'autre de la responsabilité du
signalement ce que nous en avons déduit
c'est que bien loin du traitement
hiérarchique normale rapide rigoureux qu
aurait mérité un événement impliqué un
agent de l'elysée de ce niveau de
surcroît ces dysfonctionnements témoigne
de la fébrilité de l'exécutif face à un
risque politique et risques que
représentait la diffusion de cette vidéo
sur internet et donne le sentiment que
l'elysée a vainement il faut dire
souhaitait se réserver le traitement du
problème pour se préserver d'un possible
scande voilà quelles sont les premières
conclusions sur cette chaîne des
responsabilités
s'agissant toujours des suites données
aux événements du 1er mai à l'encontre
de monsieur benalla je dois dire que
nous émettons des doutes assez clair sur
l'effectivité réel des sanctions qui ont
été infligés les informations qui
étaient recueillies par la commission
sur la portée réelle des sanctions
prononcées à l'encontre d'alexandre
benalla mais également de vincent kraz
ont permis de démentir plusieurs
explications qui avait été donnée par le
porte parole du président de la
république lors d'une conférence de
presse donnée à l'elysée le 19 juillet
2018 et qui avait fortement exagérée me
semble-t-il la réalité de la sanction
prononcée en mai concernant la mise à
pied de quinze jours qui était annoncé
d'alexion de benalla par l'elysée et
vincent crasse par les parties en marche
les auditions de notre commission ont
révélé qu'elle ne se sont en fait
traduite par aucune conséquence
financière immédiate pour les intéressés
et à ce jour nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas
la certitude que la conséquence
financière était réel concernant la
rétrogradation dont l'action de bélaye
censé avoir fait l'objet sa hiérarchie
avait mis en avant le retrait à titre de
sanction des compétences en matière de
déplacements officiels du président de
la république
toutefois il a été confirmé à notre
commission que cette décision était
provisoire et compensé par l'attribution
de nouvelles tâches et surtout ce
principe de rétrogradation a été
assortie d'importantes exception
participation à la panthéonisation de
simone veil le 1er juillet également
cérémonies du 14-juillet fait non
négligeable pour les français au retour
de l'équipe de france de football le 16
juillet et surtout maintien de
l'accompagnement des déplacements privés
du président de la république sanctions
mais surtout confiance maintenue ainsi
que je disais en préambule
alexandre bédat à conserver enfin des
moyens qui étaient inchangées ses
passeports ces véhicules voire renforcée
puisque à logements de fonction lui a
été attribué à la mi juin alors qu'il
avait été sanctionné et il continuer de
participer à la réflexion sur la mise en
place de la future direction de la
sécurité du président de la république
la commission estime donc que ces
décisions témoigne d'une volonté - de
sanctionner que de ménager dans
l'immédiat l'exposition médiatique d'
alexandre bénazet un contexte délicat
voilà le premier point clé sur lequel
nous souhaitions faire part de nos
comptes
dion présidente hiver merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs dans la
continuité de ce que vient de dire
muriel jourda
je vais aborder les questions de
sécurité vous savez ce qui est frappant
dans cette affaire c'est que dès lors
qu'il est apparu que monsieur benalla
était considéré comme disposant de
protection d'une autorité
bien que cela ne fut aucunement
formalisé dès lors que c'était perçu
comme tel
tout s'est mis à 10 fonctionné depuis
l'elysée jusqu'au ministère de
l'intérieur à la préfecture de police au
quai d'orsay et même dans les ambassades
ou sur la question des faux passeports
qu'à évoquer le président il ya eu des
comportements étranges comme si et
peut-être même jusqu'à matignon
voyez vous comme si un seul être par son
une autorité supposé faisait que tout se
mettait à dysfonctionner par cercles
successifs alors je vais vous dire au
point de vue de la sécurité que à
l'opposé de la description qui a été
fait par les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république est à
l'opposé des déclarations faites devant
la commission qui sont entre guillemets
dans le rapport et dans l' annexe à la
lettre que vous avez dans vos dossiers
déclaration faite par monsieur strzoda
par monsieur lavergne et par monsieur de
colère
il sait il est apparu que monsieur
alexandre benalla avait exercé devait
une fonction tout à fait essentiel pour
l'organisation et la gestion de la
sécurité du président de la république
au risque d'en perturber le
fonctionnement normal on a pu obtenir
non sans mal et avec retard cher
président la fiche de poste
la lettre de mission officielle qui
définissait les missions de monsieur
alexandre benalla et lorsqu on la lit et
elle figure en annexe du rapport on
constate que contrairement à ce qui a
été dit sous serment devant la
commission une mission spécifique de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république lui
étaient confiés et qu'il exerçait seul
directement sous l'autorité du directeur
de cabinet plusieurs éléments tendent à
confirmer que contrairement aux
affirmations des proches du chef de
l'état cette mission ne recouvrait pas
uniquement et loin s'en faut
des considérations à caractère
logistique à la lumière des témoignages
recueillis il apparaît qu alexandre
benalla fort de la confiance et de la
liberté d'actions qui lui étaient
accordées et dans l'ambivalence des
missions officielles qui lui étaient
confiées s'était arrogé un rôle central
dans le fonctionnement des services de
sécurité de ce qui est comme l'a rappelé
notre président la cinquième puissance
du monde
il est en particulier établi qu'il se
serait à plusieurs reprises immiscé dans
certaines décisions relevant la gestion
de la gestion du dispositif de la
sécurité du président de la république
ainsi en at il été de la mise en oeuvre
d'une cellule de réservistes de la
gendarmerie nationale au sein du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'elysée
ou du recrutement de plusieurs agents
parmi lesquels monsieur vincent kraz il
est également hautement probable qu
alexandre benalla à dans les fait
participer activement aux dispositifs de
sécurité des déplacements du chef de
l'état prenant un ascendant sur les
responsables opérationnels de la
sécurité s'imposant comme un
interlocuteur privilégié des autorités
de sécurité publique la commission
également réuni des éléments concordants
donnant à penser qu alexandre benalla
exercer dans les faits une mission et
une fonction de protection rapprochée du
président de la république ce qui a été
pourtant obstinément nier par les
principaux responsables de l'elysée que
nous avons reçues en atteste tout
d'abord son positionnement permanent à
proximité immédiate du chef de l'état
lors de déplacements auxquels ils
participaient qui de l'avis d'experts
correspondrait à une position des pôles
jeu citant dream est chargé d'évacuer le
président de la république d'en décider
si dans des situations extrêmes justifié
par le besoin de passer des messages au
chef de l'état un tel positionnement
paraît pourtant n'avoir jamais été
adopté par aucun des prédécesseurs ni
aucun des collègues d'alexandre benalla
surtout le permis de port d'armes et
j'insiste là-dessus qui lui a été
attribué en octobre 2017 par la
préfecture de police dans des conditions
inédites et dérogatoire au droit commun
à tel point que l'intéressé lui même
avait envisagé à défaut un décret secret
du président de la république pour
l'autoriser à porter une arme et nous en
fournit sont la preuve
cela ne pouvait se justifier par
d'autres raisons qu'une fonction de
protection rapprochée
le soutien appuyé de sa hiérarchie à la
demande qu'il avait formulées de même
que les contradictions devant la
commission des collaborateurs du
président de la république pour
justifier ce permis de port d'armes
accréditent l'idée qu'alexandre benalla
exercé des missions de protection
rapprochée requérant contrairement à ses
collègues le port d'une arme
il a par ailleurs reconnu avoir porté
cette arme en présence du président de
la république ce qui est sans précédent
par rapport à un certain nombre de
situations identiques par le passé
qu'elle résulte d'une volonté expresse
la hiérarchie ou d'une vision extensive
par l'intéressé des missions qu'ils y
étaient confiées il ne fait nul doute
que l'intérêt que la présence et
l'interférence d'un individu
relativement peu expérimentés et
soucieux d'affirmer son autorité dans un
milieu de professionnels aguerris
sélectionnés et formés et plus constitué
une source de dysfonctionnements et un
facteur de fragilisation du dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république la liberté les pouvoirs
excessifs laisser un chargé de mission
dans un domaine aussi sensible que la
sécurité du chef de l'état témoigne aux
yeux de notre commission de l'imprudence
de la présidence de la république dans
l'encadrement d'un individu qui avait
pourtant fait preuve par le passé de
comportement professionnel inapproprié
vous lirez le rapport la commission a
ainsi découvert qu alexandre benalla
avait été licencié de son poste de
chauffeur personnel de monsieur arnaud
montebourg alors ministre du
redressement productif en raison de son
manque de jeu site discrétion
responsabilité et transparence notamment
parce qu'il s'était prévalu du soutien
du ministre pour une demande déjà de
permis de port d'armes j'ajoute pour
finir qu'il est apparu que monsieur
benalla a participé une cellule très
restreinte associant le chef du gspr le
commandant militaire et que cette
cellule était chargé de définir une
nouvelle stratégie pour la sécurité de
la présidence de la république et du
président de la république et que
l'objectif était pour monsieur ban à la
copie
il a déclaré publiquement et entre
guillemets c'était dans le journal du
dimanche d'établir un système qui
prendrait des distances à l'égard du
ministère de l'intérieur
perçue par lui comme faisant obstacle à
cette perspective qui était sans doute
d'autonomiser quelque peu le dispositif
de sécurité du président de la
république
contrairement à la tradition qui existe
depuis le début de la vème république
pour le dispositif de sécurité du
président de la république est
exclusivement constituée de policiers et
de gendarmes relevant hier du ministère
de la défense du ministère de
l'intérieur aujourd'hui pour l'essentiel
du ministère de l'intérieur
si j'ai un collègue madame jourdain
merci monsieur président la troisième
série de dysfonctionnements que nous
avons mises à jour l'existence de graves
défaillances des autorités compétentes
pour s'assurer du retrait effectif des
prérogatives d'alexandre benalla après
son licenciement à effet du 1er août
nous avons été alertés fin décembre par
plusieurs articles de presse et dès
janvier nous avons mené une nouvelle
audition une nouvelle investigation et
nous avons eu alors la confirmation que
les diligences minimales nécessaires
pour garantir la pleine application de
l'ascension licenciement de l'action de
benalla n'avait pas été accompli par la
présidence de la république et les
ministères concernés notamment pour
s'assurer de la restitution après son
départ des moyens dont ils disposaient
uniquement pour l'exercice de ses
fonctions
le premier moyen dont il s'agit et le
téléphone théorème dans lequel on a pu
noter pour lequel on a pu noter un
manque de diligence regrettable des
services alors même qu'il s'agissait
d'un moyen de communication hautement
sécurisé qui a été présenté comme
nécessaire à l'exercice des missions de
la chefferie de cabinet encore que nous
avons pu nous convaincre de ce que
personne avant ni après monsieur b
d'alan a estimé nécessaire à ses
fonctions ce téléphone théorème
pour autant c'est un moyen hautement
sécurisés et la présidence de la
république ne s'est pas aperçue au
moment de l'inventaire du bureau de
monsieur b dallas qui a eu lieu le 2
août de la non restitution de ce
terminal théorème la présidence
république ne va s'en apercevoir qu en
octobre 2018
à l'occasion du recensement de
l'intégralité des appareils qui sont mis
à disposition
c'est à dire plusieurs mois après la
date effective du licenciement
en outre après qu en octobre 2018 la
disparition a été découverte
l'elysée ne s'est pas assuré que
l'appareil était restitué et l'elysée
c'est uniquement assuré qu'il avait été
désactivé à distance et qu'il n'a pas
été utilisé aucune demande de
restitution de l'équipement n'a été
adressée à l'ancien chargé de mission et
ça n'est qu'en janvier 2019 que ce
terminal a été rendue sur proposition
d'ailleurs du conseil d'alexandre belles
heures le deuxième série de
dysfonctionnements
s'agissant des restitutions de
restitution des moyens mis à disposition
de monsieur benalla est relative à ces
passeports lorsqu'il était en fonction à
l'elysée alexandre bédat disposait de
pas moins de quatre passeports
professionnels deux passeports
diplomatiques et deux passeports de
service
aucun n'a été restituée lors de son
licenciement
ces passeports diplomatiques ont été en
revanche utilisé à une vingtaine de
reprises 23 selon l'intéressé lui-même
entre le 1er août et le 31 décembre 2018
pour seront notamment au tchad en israël
et est probablement au maroc et aux
bahamas
ces passeports ont d'abord été attribuée
dans des conditions qui étaient
anormales l'attribution simultanée de
quatre passeports professionnels ne
semble ni courante ni justifiées à ce
niveau de responsabilité est d'ailleurs
l'intéressé n'a pas été capable de s'en
expliquer se contentant de se retrancher
derrière la responsabilité des
ministères qui avait accepté de lui
délivrer ses titres successifs
le motif de délivrance du premier
passeport de service nous l'avons
découvert au cours de nos investigations
est un passeport qui a été délivré
lorsque monsieur ménard a était en
détachement comme chef de cabinet
à la délégation interministérielle pour
l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer en 2016 et ce premier motif
ne manque pas de surprendre puisque ce
document était réclamée en vue d'un seul
déplacement pour répondre à l'invitation
du président de l'office européen des
brevets qui est l organe d'emploi
d'élection de benalla et surtout pour se
rendre en allemagne alors même qu'un
passeport n'est pas utile pour se rendre
en allemagne mais il a été délivré pour
ce motif
le renouvellement du premier passeport
diplomatique a eu lieu le 24 mai 2018
alors même que monsieur benalla revenait
suite à sa suspension disciplinaire et
alors qu'il n'aurait normalement dû
conserver aucun rôle en matière de
déplacements internationaux et en outre
selon l'elysée cette demande aurait été
faite par monsieur benalla lui même sans
passer par le service du protocole ni
l'échelon hiérarchique supérieur
enfin s'agissant du mode de délivrance
de ces passeports concernant
l'utilisation allégués d'un faux
documents pour l'obtention du second
passeport de service
il appartient à la justice de se
prononcer sur responsabilité pénale
d'alexandre benhadda puisque il nous
avait été indiqué que ce passeport avait
été fourni alors même que la demande
avait été faite par monsieur b dallas
lui-même rejeté pour ce motif est à
nouveau reformuler sur la base d'un
document qui n'aurait en réalité paraît
émaner de sa hiérarchie
ce que nous pouvons regretter la justice
étant saisi ce que nous pouvons
regretter toutefois s'est vivement
c'est que ces faits qui sont connues
depuis l'automne 2010 8 par l'elysée et
bien n'ont été signalés aux parquets
qu'en janvier 2019 et on peut le dire
sous la pression médiatique puisque en
réalité ils ont été signalés le matin
même de l'audition du directeur de
cabinet du président par notre
commission
suite à ces conditions d'attribution
quelque peu étrange
nous avons constaté également une
restitution tardive
faute de démarches efficaces en réalité
de ces passeports le siac sommet n'a été
licencié pour faute à compter du 1er
août 2010 8 pendant plus de cinq mois
les différentes administrations ont été
incapables d'obtenir de lui la
restitution effective et définitive de
ces titres de voyage
la restitution a été effective en
janvier 2019 sauf pour un des passeports
de service qui a été déclaré perdu par
monsieur alexandre bédat les démarches
accomplies par les différentes
administrations se sont limités d'abord
à des lettres de relance qui n'ont pas
été suivies d'effet et en réalité seuls
les révélations dans la presse ont
conduit l'administration à envisager
bien sûr bien plus tardivement des
poursuites pénales
enfin plutôt ensuite nous avons pu
constater une invalidation assez
laborieuse des passeports diplomatiques
car des délais très importants se sont
écoulées avant que les diligences
efficaces soient effectués pour empêcher
l'utilisation des passeports
diplomatiques nous a été indiqué que
deux éléments s'opposait à la validation
de ces passeports d'abord l'absence
d'une décision de justice qui aurait été
nécessaire et ensuite l'absence d'un
lieu d'un logiciel adéquat pour
permettre de faire entrer dans ce
logiciel le motif d'invalidation propre
à la situation de monsieur benalla cette
demande
en réalité elle a été faite en novembre
je rappelle que le licenciement et à
effet du 1er juillet 2018
cette demande d'invalidation concernant
les références des passeports
diplomatiques avec son média a été
transmise par le quai d'orsay au
ministère de l'intérieur en novembre
pour se voir poser le 26 décembre 2018
les impossibilités techniques et les
problèmes informatiques que je vous ai
signalé
pourtant après que la presse a dévoilé
le 27 6 décembre qu alexandre bédat
avait pu conserver et utiliser jusqu'à
ce jour le passeport diplomatique
ces difficultés ont été rapidement et
opportunément lever et l invalidation a
eu lieu ceci étant indépendamment des
difficultés de techniques de logiciels
qui nous ont été signalés il est assez
surprenant qu'aucune instruction
individuelle n'était donnée à la police
de l'air et des frontières par le
ministère de l'intérieur pour empêcher
l'utilisation d'un tel titre de voyage
lors de la sortie du territoire national
par monsieur benalla ce manque initial
de réactivité des services puis leurs
problèmes de coordination a ainsi permis
alexandre benhaddad continue à utiliser
ces titres de voyage à 23 reprises entre
le 1er août et le 31 décembre pour
sortir du territoire national monsieur
le président en sueur merci dans la
continuité toujours de ce que vient
d'exprimer muriel jourda
je vais vous dire quelques mots sur les
contrats russe car en effet cette
affaire est une affaire gigogne et il
est heureux voyez vous je me permets
cette incidence que le sénat existe car
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
ayant créé une commission d' enquête qui
a explosé en vol comme les décisions
qu'ils eussent tt opportune ainsi que
l'a dit notre président philippe bas
n'ont pas été prises le 2 mai ni
d'ailleurs le 3 mai lit d'ailleurs
jusqu'à la parution d'un article dans le
journal le monde
eh bien eux il est heureux que des
parlementaires aient pu enquêter faire
leur travail ce que nous faisons sur
tous les sujets sans aucune restriction
dès lors que nous étions dans le cadre
de notre mission et c'est très important
parce que ce qui apparaît maintenant on
pourrait nous dire que ce n'est pas
essentiellement dans le cadre de notre
mission
mais dès lors qu'il s'agit de
financement de contrats qui ont été
conclues pendant que monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz était à l'elysée où
étaient en lien avec l'elysée
il y à là quelque chose qui est
considérable pour les conséquences
éventuelles par rapport à la sécurité
non seulement de la présidence de la
république ce qui n'est pas rien vous en
conviendrez
mais au delà
mise en avant dès le début des travaux
de notre commission le manque de
précautions et de diligence de la
présidence de la république dans la
prévention des conflits d'intérêts de
certains de ses collaborateurs pendant
ou après l'exercice de leurs fonctions
s'est confirmée au fil des révélations
sur l'affairé dite des contrats russe la
commission n'a pas pu procéder sur ce
sujet à des demandes d'informations
complémentaires dans les délais impartis
à l'exercice des pouvoirs
d'investigation qui lui ont été
consentis par le sénat pour six mois le
23 juillet 2018
elle tire néanmoins des informations
qu'elle a réuni trois conclusions
majeures d'abord en matière de faux
témoignages les informations révélées
par la presse en particulier les
enregistrements qui ont donné lieu à
diverses péripéties parues dans la
presse également les enregistrements
donc publié par le journal mediapart le
31 juillet janvier 2019 et les
déclarations publiques faites par
monsieur jean maurice bernard président
d'une société qui dans le contexte où
nous sommes s'appelle bizarrement
velours peu lourd
le 11 février sur bfm tv laisse à penser
qu alexandre benalla et vincent kraz se
sont rendus coupables lors de leur
audition devant la commission des lois
du sénat le 21 janvier de faux
témoignages premièrement sur les trois
points suivants premièrement
l'implication d'alexandre benalla dans
la négociation et la conclusion du
contrat liant la société mars
on parle velours mars à et un
représentant de l'oligarque russe
monsieur iskander makhmoudov
profondément lié à monsieur poutine
d'ailleurs comme l'a dit je crois que
c'est notre président ce matin il y à
peu tôt les gars qu russe qui ne soit
pas lié
monsieur poutine deuxième point
l'engagement des négociations en vue de
la conclusion de ce contrat dès le mois
de mars 2018 j'attire l'attention
mesdames et messieurs sur cette date
dès le mois de mars 2018 alors que
alexandre benalla et vincent grass était
encore en fonctions à l'elysée
troisièmement l'implication de vincent
kra dans la reprise du contrat à compter
d'octobre 2018 par une nouvelle société
dont il nous a dit qu'ils s'appellent
joue quoi france clause protection en
francs en français dans le texte
dot monsieur kraz nous a dit que c'était
par une coïncidence qu'elle avait été
créé le jour où l'autre avait été fermée
justement à la même adresse
ce que nous avons écouté avec attention
comme toujours
deuxième point un g10 trois conclusions
majeures ça c'est la première conclusion
deuxième conclusion les révélations sur
la sphère des contrats russe tendent à
établir l'existence de conflits
d'intérêts majeurs
l'implication de monsieur alexandre
benalla de monsieur vincent grass dans
la négociation et la conclusion
d'activités de nature privée qui plus
est pour le compte de sociétés
appartenant à des intérêts étrangers
puissant donc adjoint au chef de cabinet
qui négocie avec une société d intérêts
financiers liés directement à un état
étranger est au plus haut niveau de cet
état étranger constituerait non
seulement une faute déontologique majeur
pour les intéressés mais également un
risque pour la présidence de la
république et pour notre république il
ne fait en effet nul doute que les
relations indirectes entretenu avec un
oligarque russe par un proche
collaborateur du chef de l'état
directement impliqués on l'a vu dans la
sécurité de la présidence de la
république et d'un réserviste du
commandement militaire du palais de
l'élysée exercer une responsabilité
d'encadrement seraient de nature en
raison de dépendance de la dépendance
financière qu'elle implique a affecté la
sécurité du chef de l'état et les
intérêts de notre pays
les ramifications de cette affaire des
contrats russe jusqu'à matignon et au
sein de l'armée française se précise à
travers un autre de ses protagonistes
monsieur choukri va crime présentait
comme le compagnon de la responsable du
groupe de sécurité du premier ministre
madame marie elodie poitou qui a depuis
lors démissionnait de ses fonctions et
par ailleurs sous-officier monsieur
wakrim je précise sous-officier affecté
au commandement des opérations spéciales
donc dans un cercle très circonstancié
du renseignement ne manque pas
d'inquiéter quant aux risques de
vulnérabilité que ses activités
commerciales ont fait courir aux plus
hautes institutions de l'état c'est la
deuxième conclusion voici la troisième
alors que la sphère des contrats russe
met en lumière d'importants
dysfonctionnements au plus haut niveau
de l'état
il est certain que la présidence de la
république a péché par manque de
précaution en ne prenant pas toutes les
mesures qui paraissent absolument
nécessaire pour s'assurer que les
intérêts privés de certains de ses
collaborateurs n'interférerait pas avec
l'exercice de leurs fonctions et ne
commettrai pas leur ne compromettrait
pas excusez moi leur indépendance dès le
début de ses travaux la commission en
effet mis en avant le fait qu'alexandre
benalla comme d'ailleurs cet autre agent
nommé en qualité de chargé de mission à
l'elysée échapper à toute transparence
alors même qu'ils exerçaient des
missions importantes ainsi qu'une
influence certaine sur la réflexion et
les décisions du chef de l'état s'est
chargé de mission employés au sein du
cabinet de la présidence de république
n'ont pas rempli n'ont pas déposé de
déclaration d'intérêt ni de déclaration
patrimoniale au mépris de l'article 11
de la loi du 11 octobre 2013 relative à
la transparence de la vie publique qui
s'applique évidemment à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs du président de la
république au sein du cabinet en tout
cas l'affairé dite des contrats russe
attestent des conséquences d'une telle
négligence
le fait qu'il n'ait été demandé à
alexandre benalla de respecter ses
obligations de déclaration qu'il n'ait
pas été demandé à descendre benalla de
respecter ses obligations de déclaration
a privé l'elysée de la possibilité de
bénéficier des prérogatives de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique afin d'enquêter sur d'éventuels
conflits d'intérêts et permettre en cas
de déclaration
son cher ou de déclarations incomplètes
sur des intérêts privés et sur des
intérêts privés produisant des contrats
dont les sommes sont parus les montants
sont parus dans la presse et chacun a vu
que c'était loin d'être négligeable donc
la haute autorité n'a pas pu enquêter ni
même statuer sur ces questions voilà
pour la question des contrats russe
merci cher monsieur le rapporteur
madame jourdain va vous présenter je
crois la liste des principaux
dysfonctionnements dont nous avons fait
l'inventaire
merci monsieur le président à titre
liminaire avant de présenter cette liste
je voudrais indiquer qu à ce stade je
pense que vous avez saisies
comment la commission a travaillé et
l'évolution de notre travail nous avons
été saisis initialement du
fonctionnement de l'état sur les faits
qui se sont déroulés le 1er mai la
contrer ce cas ces faits concernaient ne
s'écrase mais surtout monsieur benalla
c'est sans doute celui sur le calme aux
sondes nous sommes le plus attardés
parce que les faits qui ont succédé ont
plus concernés monsieur paix d'allah et
monsieur benalla nous a été présenté au
début des auditions comme plutôt un bon
élément à l'elysée puis à la fin des
solutions comme un individu pour
reprendre le terme qui a été employé un
peu moins recommandables mais s'il ya
une chose qu'il n'a pas varié dans la
façon dont les choses nous ont été
présentés c'est le fait qu'il s'agissait
d'un individu qui avait des agissements
qui étaient isolés et qui ne pouvait pas
être mis en lien avec sa fonction à
l'elysée or au fur et à mesure de nos
auditions au fur et à mesure de la
réception des documents que nous avons
demandé des réponses aux questions nous
avons formulé au fur et à mesure aussi
des éléments que nous avons pu trouver
dans la presse et dans les médias de
manière générale eh bien nous avons
découvert qu'en réalité si ces éléments
si ces agissements étaient ceux d'un
homme
il n'avait été possible que parce qu'ils
évoluent est dans un système qui avait
du fait de ces dysfonctionnements rendu
possible toutes les anomalies
que nous avons pu trouver et la thèse de
la faute de l'homme isolé s'est effacé
au profit du dysfonctionnement d'une
institution qui a rendu possibles ces
multiples situations anormales allant
jusqu'à affectés et je crois que jean
pierre sur l'a10 très bien la sécurité
du président de la république alors ses
principaux dysfonctionnements que nous
avons constaté ils sont lesquels et sont
d'abord deux majeurs nous semble-t-il
ces dysfonctionnements au sein des
services de l'état et ils ont pu
affecter non seulement la sécurité du
président de la république mais
également les intérêts de notre pays il
s'agit d'abord des pouvoirs excessifs
qui ont été laissés à un collaborateur
inexpérimentés dans un domaine la
sécurité du chef de l'état pourtant
essentiel à la continuité de l'état et
je me référais ou développements faits
sur ce point par le président bah nous
avons découvert aussi la nomination
atypiques comme lieutenant colonel de
réserve opérationnelle de la gendarmerie
nationale qui a été celle de monsieur
vinolas nous ne l'avons pas reprises
mais cela est resté présent à l'esprit
de tous
nous avons également mis à jour cette
confiance maintenue et cette
collaboration poursuivi après les graves
dérapages commis par ce collaborateur le
1er mai 2010huit également une remontée
d'informations défaillante au sein
d'institutions policière et de
l'exécutif sur les faits du 1er mai une
dissimulation des faits à la justice du
fait de l'absence de saisine du
procureur de la république au titre de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
une première sanction discrète je vais
indiquer et dont la portée réelle n'est
pas établie à sérieux manque de
précautions dans la prévention des
conflits d'intérêts de certains
collaborateurs du président de la
république un manque de diligence dans
le suivi le retrait des moyens alloués
alexandre bédat après son licenciement
passeport téléphone jeudi revient pas
une réaction plus tardive pour s'assurer
du respect par l'intéressé de ses
obligations déontologiques à l'issue du
contrat et enfin un contrôle insuffisant
des affectations des réservistes au sein
du dispositif de sécurité de l'elysée il
s'agit là bien sûr de monsieur crasse
voilà quels sont ces dysfonctionnements
monsieur présidente qui ont été relevés
est-ce que vous pouvez aborder
maintenant
les propositions je crois que vous vous
répartissez il leur énoncé ce
présidentielle merci monsieur le
président donc nous allons faire 13
propositions
alors bien entendu dans le respect de
leur respect je vais présenter six
propositions et muriel jourda on
présentera sept
ça va alors première proposition
on développera si vous avez des
questions pour le moment on va les
énoncés première proposition réformer le
cadre réglementaire relatif au groupe de
sécurité de la présidence de la
république gspr afin d'une part de
réaffirmer la compétence exclusive des
membres des forces de sécurité
intérieure pour assurer la sécurité du
chef de l'état d'autre part formaliser
les règles et procédures de recrutement
au sein de ce gspr proposition numéro 2
maintenir la responsabilité organique du
ministère de l'intérieur sur le groupe
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république
ce qui nous paraît absolument essentiel
sur le plan des institutions
républicaines
ç'a toujours été comme ça depuis le
début de la vème république
je le rappelle pour maintenir la
responsabilité organique du ministère de
l'intérieur sur le groupe de sécurité de
la présidence de la république et
prévoir la vie du chef du service de la
protection sur la composition de ce
groupe proposition numéro 3 rappelé par
voie de circulaire les règles
déontologiques devant régir les
relations entre les collaborateurs de la
présidence de la république ceux des
cabinets ministériels et les
administrations centrales proposition
numéro 4 mettre fin à l'expérience des
collaborateur officieux du président de
la république et faire respecter
strictement leurs obligations
déclaratives à tous les chargés de
mission de l'elysée proposition numéro 5
conditionner le recrutement des
collaborateurs du président de la
république à la réalisation d'une
enquête administrative préalable afin de
s'assurer de la compatibilité de leur
comportement avec les fonctions ou des
missions susceptibles de leur être
confiées proposition numéro 6
prévoir par la loi des sanctions pénales
en cas de manquement aux obligations de
déclaration d'une nouvelle activité à la
commission de déontologie de la fonction
publique
ce qui n'a pas été fait dans le cas de
monsieur benalla ni avant ni bien sûr
après maintenant je vais terminer ou les
six propositions d'aujourd'hui
ainsi monsieur le président la
proposition numéro 7 a trait directement
à notre saisine qui avait mis en avant
un dysfonctionnement l'état qui
consistait pour un collaborateur de
l'elysée à intervenir dans une mission
de maintien de l'ordre qui relèvent
elles de l'action du gouvernement si
l'exécutif est constitué de deux pôles
le président de la république et le
gouvernement
ils ne doivent pas interférer dans
l'action l'un de l'autre de sorte que
notre proposition numéro 7 est de mettre
fin à la pratique des conseillers
communs au président de la république au
premier ministre pour respecter la
distinction constitutionnel des
fonctions présidentielles et
gouvernementales seul le gouvernement
étant responsable devant le parlement la
proposition numéro en numéro 8 dans le
cadre d'une plus grande transparence et
d'enrichir leurs rapports déposés
annuellement lors de l'examen du projet
de loi de finances les connaisseurs
selon ce que c'est que la nex budgétaire
jaune ce rapport étant consacré aux
personnels affectés dans les cabinets
ministériels l'enrichir d'un volet
supplémentaire permettant de dresser un
tableau du nombre des missions et des
rémunérations des personnels affectés à
la présidence de la république
la proposition numéro 9 consiste à
renforcer la transparence des
recrutements dans les différentes
réserves de la gendarmerie nationale et
la rigueur des règles de sélection dans
la composante spécialiste de sa réserve
opérationnelle avec un référentiel de
compétences techniques ou théoriques
rechercher un niveau élevé de formation
ou d'expérience professionnelle
nécessaire pour postuler une
vérification une appréciation préalable
par un jury pour près
arrêt et appuyer la décision du
directeur général la proposition numéro
10 consiste à rendre obligatoire
l'établissement d'une liste des
activités professionnelles exercées par
les réservistes du commandement
militaire du palais de l'elysée les deux
autres propositions 11 et 12 août 12 ont
trait au renforcement des pouvoirs du
contrôle du parlement la proposition
numéro 11 consiste à conforter le
pouvoir de contrôle du parlement sur les
services sur les services de la
présidence de la république non passion
de président de la république mais bien
sûr les services de la présidence de la
république
la proposition numéro 12 consiste à
établir et confirmé la plénitude des
pouvoirs d'investigation des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires dans le respect
du principe de la séparation des
pouvoirs du secret de l'instruction
y compris quand la justice enquête de
son côté sur des crimes et délits à
propos des mêmes fait en exerçant le
contrôle parlementaire sous l'angle
exclusif du fonctionnement de l'état
je peux peut-être illustré monsieur le
président cette proposition car il y à
une nombreux débats sur le fait que
notre commission puisse enquêter alors
que la justice était saisie sur des
faits qui était proche dont on pouvait
penser qu'ils étaient similaires et nous
avons toujours défendu le fait que la
justice et le parlement bénéficier de
pouvoirs qui étaient concurrents et de
même valeur constitutionnelle mais ne
s'exerçait pas sur les mêmes éléments ce
qui est expliqué très bien par le
président m'a tout à l'heure puisque
nous nous exerçons le contrôle du
fonctionnement de l'état et nous pouvons
dire qu'à l'occasion de notre mission
nous avons été suivis par la justice car
nous avions demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur un dossier qui avait été
saisi et mis sous scellés le ministère
de l'intérieur nous l'a refusée pour ce
motif
nous sommes donc adressé au juge
d'instruction qui détenait ce dossier eh
bien il a tout simplement lever les
scellés est rendu ce dossier au
ministère pour que nous puissions lui
refaire cette demande le juge a donc
estimé que nous pouvions obtenir cet
élément quand bien même une enquête
judiciaire était en cours mais il est
important
par cette proposition de clarifier ces
éléments et enfin la proposition numéro
13 consiste à mieux définir la portée
juridique d obligation de signalement au
parquet découlant de l'article 40 du
code de procédure pénale
et d'en informer largement l'ensemble
des élus responsables et agents publics
voilà monsieur le président merci chers
collègues
j'espère que les travaux de nos
rapporteur de la commission des lois
seront utiles qui seront utiles aux
français bien sûr puisque notre travail
s'est fait en toute transparence sous
leur regard et en leur nom mais aussi
utile à l'exécutif par les
recommandations qui viennent de vous est
présentée et dont j'espère que elles
apparaîtront pour ce qu'elles sont c'est
à dire des recommandations constructives
dont une partie d'ailleurs vise
simplement à ce que les règles soient
respectées
je voudrais revenir un instant sur la
lettre que nous avons écrite au
président du sénat pour que le bureau du
sénat soit saisi pour vous indiquer la
motivation fondamentale qui a été la
mienne et celle des deux rapporteurs
il s'agit pour nous en pensant au
respect des prérogatives nécessaires du
parlement pour eux l'avenir de poser une
exigence l'exigence de dire la vérité au
parlement et cette exigence qui existe
dans l' ordonnance de 1958 ne doit pas
rester lettre morte car sinon c'est un
droit essentiel que nous exerçons au nom
du peuple français qui seraient bafoués
et c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
nous avons souhaité que le bureau
délibère de la possibilité de saisir le
procureur de la république c'est le
président sur vous voulez ajouter
quelque chose merci beaucoup monsieur le
président je voulais ajouter deux choses
premièrement nous avons tenu e muriel
jourda et moi même a co signé cette
lettre avec l'accord bien entendu du
président philippe pas pourquoi
pour montrer notre totale unité bien que
chacun sache que nous n'appartenons pas
à des groupes différents
nous appartenons à des groupes
différents tu vois c'est un lapsus ou
nous appartenons donc à des groupes
différents et je voulais dire que dans
cette affaire finalement nous n'avions
que un objectif connaître la vérité dire
la vérité
connaître les dysfonctionnements les
mettre à jour le plus possible et tirer
les conséquences prévues par l'
ordonnance et ce qui est important c'est
la lettre que vous avez dans votre
dossier
mais j'insiste c'est aussi la nex la
lettre carl alex à la lettre comprend
toute une série de citations entre
guillemets qui ont été faites sous
serment devant la commission et qui
justifient les préconisations qu'il y a
dans la lettre par rapport auquel nous
prenons naturellement nos
responsabilités devant le président du
sénat le bureau du sénat et bien sûr
devant le parquet la justice si ce que
nous espérons nous sommes suivis par nos
collègues
ça c'est la première marque seconde
remarque cette lettre elle a été écrite
avec beaucoup de soin et nous avons
peser chaque mot
il y a trois points différents
comme l'a dit déjà monsieur bah est à
trois points différents
premièrement s'agissant de monsieur
benalla et de monsieur kraz au vu des
travaux de la commission
les informations collecte collecter et
des obus des travaux de la commission
des informations collectées et de
plusieurs déclarations sous serment de
monsieur alexandre ménard et vincent
kraz dont le détail figure en annexe du
présent courrier
nous sommes conduits à considérer que
celles ci constituent des faux
témoignages
premier point deuxième point s'agissant
des trois personnes déjà cité de
l'elysée monsieur strzoda monsieur
colère et monsieur lavergne il est fait
état d informations qu'ils ont apportés
et il est dit que notre enquête a mis à
jour dans leurs déclarations un certain
nombre d'omissions d'incohérences et de
contradictions pour leur élevé figure en
annexe
et nous disons que qu'ils ont retenues
je prends les termes exacts une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission lors de leurs auditions
notamment sur le périmètre de la mission
de sécurité exercées par monsieur
benalla dès lors nous demandons au
bureau au présent au bureau du sénat de
faire part de ces éléments et enfin
troisièmement et je me permets
d'insister là dessus
notre lettre comprend cet élément nous
saisissons le parking vous proposons de
saisir le parquet afin qu'ils apprécient
s'il ya lieu de procéder à des
investigations concernant d'autres
personnes et d'autres fins que celles et
ceux que nous venons d'expliquer
d'évoquer explicitement
nous n'avons pas mis cette phrase de
manière comme une clause de style il y à
toute une série d'éléments dans le
dossier dans dans le dans le rapport est
aussi dans le document annexé à la
lettre qui peuvent conduire une série
d'investigations
vous comprendrez bien que lorsqu'il ya
des contradictions
on ne sait pas toujours qui a tort et
qui a raison puisqu'ils la contradiction
entre des déclarations
donc il y a trois points différents qui
sont marqués de manière différente
c'est important de le dire le premier
pour deux personnes le second qui
concerne en particulier trois personnes
et le dernier qui concerne toute
personne citée dans le rapport
susceptibles de donner lieu à des
enquêtes à la diligence du parquet donc
nous faisons cela à voyez-vous ensemble
en prenant nos responsabilités et en en
ayant conscience vraiment de faire en
conscience ce qui nous est demandé par
la constitution de notre république
merci cher collègue madame jourdain oui
merci monsieur président effectivement
je m'associe aux propos qui viennent
d'être tenus et bien qu'il s'agisse
d'une prérogative du président de la
commission jean pierre sueur et moi même
nous avons tenu à nous associer à ce
courrier en responsabilité le contrôle
du parlement est une fonction qui est le
marqueur de la démocratie donc il nous
paraissait essentiel que cette fonction
soit respectée et pour cela
effectivement il ne faut pas que l'on
puisse mentir et ne pas dire la vérité
lors des commissions d'information de
commission d'enquêté des missions
d'information que nous menons et il nous
apparaissait essentiel de saisir le
bureau du sénat pour que le parquet
puisse à son tour être saisi sur ce
point eh bien merci chers collègues
merci de votre patience mesdames et
messieurs il se pourrait qu'il y ait une
ou plusieurs questions
s'il vous plaît je suis contraint calme
et je travaille pour public sénat car
regarde ce que vous portez sur la
pression qui a été exercée sur la
commission depuis le mois de juillet il
ya les mots destitution qui ont été
prononcées qui était une volonté qu'on
vous prêtait et également le fait que
voilà il y avait cette expression qu'il
vienne me chercher
quel regard que vous portez sur cette
pression assez phénoménal aussi de la
part de la garde des sceaux qui a qu'à
attaquer vos travaux alors en termes de
séparation des pouvoirs est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire votre sentiment sur
cette question
ces légumes des choses c'était il ya
longtemps c'est à dire il y a quatre
mois et nous n'avons pas attachés à ces
tentatives de créer la polémique ou de
pression la moindre importance
senna est libre et indépendant il a fait
son travail avec sérénité avec humilité
aussi en s'efforçant de répondre à la
tante d'objectivité qui je crois a été
placée en lui il n'y a rien à ajouter
sauf peut-être que je veux remercier de
la qualité de leur collaboration
l'ensemble des personnes aux réserves
que nous avons indiqué tout à l'heure
qui ont été auditionnés mais aussi vous
dire que je suis très heureux comme les
rapporteurs d'avoir pu rassembler à
l'appart à partir de nos demandes
écrites une documentation très
volumineuse puisque elle atteint près de
500 pages et qui a comporté beaucoup
d'éléments d'information dont vous avez
trouvé la trace dans l'exposé des deux
rapporteurs et qui s'ajoute aux
informations que nous avons recueillies
recueillies en audition bonjour as
dynamite chaouch pour quotidien oui on a
le sentiment que ce sous le pression on
a le sentiment que c'est sous la
pression de votre travail au sénat et du
travail de journaliste que la sphère
puis avancez jusqu au placement en
détention provisoire hier d'alexandre
benalla question la justice est-elle
at-elle été trop lente dans cette
affaire et deuxième question sommes-nous
selon vous en présence d'un scandale
d'état
ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
après avoir été si sourcilleux si
vigilant dans le respect du travail de
la justice que nous allons aujourd'hui
et les rapporteurs et moi même faire des
commentaires sur le travail de la
justice quant à la qualification de ce
qu'est cette affaire benalla ça n'a
aucune importance
ce qui est important pour nous c'est que
nous avons constaté des
dysfonctionnements nous avons proposé
des recommandations pour qu'il y soit
mis fin il y à d'ailleurs été mis fin
avant même nos recommandations pour un
certain nombre de ces dysfonctionnements
effectivement grâce à un bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
auquel le parlement à travers nous je
crois aura eu sa part mais les médias
eux mêmes rues une grande part dans ce
résultat
et ça ça inspire de la confiance dans le
fonctionnement des des institutions de
notre pays
et puis ça montre toute l'importance en
démocratie de mettre sous le regard des
nos concitoyens des françaises et des
français en l'occurrence ce qui ne va
pas pour que se soit améliorée monsieur
sûr je voulais ajouter un complément
mais pas sur ça j'aurais été un peu
frustré suite à votre question je
voulais quand même saluer l'effort de
rhétorique de madame le garde des sceaux
qui nous a gratifié d'une dissertation
dans le journal le monde pour nous
expliquer l'article 51 alinéa 2 de la
constitution
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un effort que
je tiens à saluer nous étions nous
avions lu par nous mêmes la constitution
et je voulais dire très très aimablement
comme toujours que s'il était tout à
fait intéressant de voir que les aux
autorités de l'exécutif était très
préoccupé du fait que nous n'avons
piétions pas nous pouvoir législatif sur
le pouvoir le judiciaire elle pourrait
aussi s'interroger sur l'utilité de pour
le pouvoir exécutif de ne pas empiéter
sur les prérogatives du pouvoir
législatif
aulas c'est fini et réciproquement nous
sommes attentifs aux prérogatives de
chaque institution madame jorda
oui popo répondre également à cette
première question de quentin qu'elle met
des mots forts ont été prononcées c'est
vrai comme le mode destitution je pense
que la restitution de nos travaux
aujourd'hui aura permis d'apaiser des
craintes si elle existait encore nous
sommes concentrés sur le fonctionnement
de l'état et est nullement sur ce qu on
nous prêtait comme intention que nous
n'avons jamais eu madame janica milite
du parisien j'essaie de comprendre les
conclusions auxquelles vous arrive et il
me semble que vous faites mais je peux
être me tromper je des distinctions
entre omissions mensonges contradictions
et faux témoignages notamment pour
messieurs benalla et messieurs kraz est
ce que je me trompe ou est ce le cas
est-ce que ça entraîne des conséquences
différentes sur le ce que vous allez
demander à au bureau de
du sénat monsieur sur par avance répondu
à cette question montre en effet il y à
une distinction entre les trois cas que
vous citez le cas de monsieur benalla le
cas des collaborateurs du président de
la république qui au début de notre
travail ont opposé des dénégations donc
question que nous posions sur l'exercice
de responsabilités en matière de
sécurité par monsieur benalla avant que
la présidence de la république elle-même
admettent des responsabilités de
sécurité de monsieur benalla quelques
semaines après au moment où nous avions
demandé communication de la fiche de
fonctions de l'intéressé et puis comme
sur l'a expliqué tout à l'heure il y a
dans les témoignages reçus des
contradictions et quand il ya des
contradictions il y en a les auteurs de
ces contradictions
certains ont dit la vérité d'autres pas
mais nous ne sommes pas en mesure les
opposant les uns aux autres de savoir et
il appartiendra au procureur de la
république s'il est saisi d'apprécier
s'il ya lieu qu'il approfondisse ses
contradictions pour déterminer
l'existence éventuelle là aussi de faux
témoignage est attribuée de tels faux
témoignage à leurs auteurs ce que nous
sommes incapables de faire quand deux
personnes nous disent des choses qui
s'opposent
si nous n'avons pas suffisamment
d'éléments de fait pour trancher entre
leurs témoignages et savoir qui dit vrai
et qui dit faux et puis il peut arriver
aussi que quelqu'un dise faut de bonne
foi et sans et sans mentir
donc vous voyez que quand les questions
se poseront à la justice elle portera
une appréciation différente de celle que
nous pauvres portée et avec des moyens
différents
nous avons nous le serment mais nous
n'avons pas la garde à vue
nous n'avons pas toutes les dix sociaux
que peu utilisé la justice quand elle
poursuit la recherche de la vérité sur
d'éventuelles infractions
je vais à 6 h oui permettez moi ça veut
dire le ce que vous appelez ce que vous
n'appelez pas officiellement si je puis
dire ou juridiquement je ne sais pas
faux témoignages que vous appelez
omission contradictions et mensonges je
crois vous préconisez en tout cas vous
proposer tout de même que ça puisse mais
l'objet de la saisine du procureur
monsieur tu vas vous précisez soyons
extrêmement clair la lettre vous l'avez
donc vous pouvez la lire vous avez tous
un dans le dossier bon il est tout à
fait clair que dans tous les cas nous
proposons au président du sénat et au
bureau du sénat de saisir le parquet
c'est clair premièrement pour monsieur
benalla écrase avec des formules que
nous avons écrites et que j'ai lu tout à
l'heure donc c'est clair
en parlant de faux témoignages
deuxièmement nous demandons que pour les
collaborateurs de l'elysée précités le
parquet soit saisie au nom d'omissions
d'incohérences et de contradictions et
au nom du fait que les personnes
concernées ont retenu une part
significative de la vérité à la
commission et troisièmement nous
proposons que soient envoyées l'ensemble
du rapport c'est à dire le rapport
lui-même plus la lettre qui a annexé
plus les témoignages qui sont annexés à
la lettre si vous lisez l'ensemble des
témoignages vous verrez qu'il y a
matière à s'interroger sur un certain
nombre de personnes qui n'ont pas été
précédemment cités mais qui sont dans le
rapport
et enfin est aussi annexée au rapport
l'ensemble des comptes rendus des
auditions
donc nous nous disons ce que nous
croyons devoir dire en conscience par
rapport aux différentes personnes
que nous avons cités et avec les
qualificatifs que nous avons définies et
nous en prenons la responsabilité mais
dans les trois cas il s'agit de saisir
le parquet avec des motivations que nous
assumons mais dans le troisième cas
c'est une saisine très large car nous
avons le sentiment que cette saisine
large et en l'espèce absolument
justifiés sans cela nous n'aurions pas
indiqué dans la lettre
je crois que c'est clair enfin j'espère
merci je fais ce que l'on verse pieux où
ils bonjour simon le baron de france
info pour compléter la question de ma
consoeur du parisien est ce que vous
pouvez nous re préciser nous résumer
quels sont les omissions les
contradictions les incohérences que vous
avez relevé dans les déclarations de
monsieur strzoda colère et la vergne et
il y en a sept pages monsieur alors je
vous recommande de d'en prendre
connaissance puisque tout est rendu
public
dans le détail nous n'allons pas lire
les sept pages devant vous on a tout
près sûr on a tout impossible
on a tout dit impossible que je fais de
la radio c'est pour s'exprimer bien sûr
mais tout faux et là je nous comptons
sur votre travail de journaliste pour
informer vos auditeurs à partir de la
totale transparence que nous avons fait
et j'ai aussi et nous sommes à votre
disposition dans la radio voilà alors je
crois se calmait
j'avais une deuxième question est ce que
vous avez travaillé sur tout ce qui
s'est passé depuis depuis les faits de
la place de la contrescarpe est ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir une autre commission d'
enquête notamment sur la question des
passeports diplomatiques est ce que vous
proposez à vos collègues sénateurs de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
vous voilà de vous deux vous suivrez de
vous emboîter le pas dans dans ses
travaux parce qu'il ya encore des choses
à découvrir selon vous elle c'est une
question qui peut se poser maintenant
vous avez beaucoup d'idées pour nous
celle là ne l'avions pas lui on pour les
passeports diplomatiques
la chose essentielle c'est quand même
que monsieur benhaddad demande le
renouvellement du passeport le jour même
où il est déchargé de toutes les
missions de toutes les fonctions qui
justifierait qu'il est un passeport
diplomatique qui le demandent
directement sans passer par le service
du protocole de l'elysée il obtient le
quai d'orsay
ea dont dix au service du protocole qui
lui a délivré le passeport
et il ne se passe rien c'est à dire que
le service vieux protocole ignorent sans
doute le fait que monsieur pénale a été
déchargé des fonctions en raison
desquelles il a obtenu par cette voix
étrange un passeport à un moment où il
en avait il a eu le droit d'en avoir
voyez c'est le signe que tous this
fonctionne et un peu se déglingue à
partir du moment où les gens pensent que
c'est monsieur b dallas et qu'il a une
autorité particulière
même chose pour tous et bien mesdames et
messieurs je vous remercie beaucoup de
l'intérêt que vous avez de nouveau
portée à nos travaux et je vous souhaite
bon courage maintenant parce que c'est
vous qui prenez le relais
la conférence de presse est terminée